in this video we're going to think about
what makes a poll or a survey credible
because remember the whole reason why
we're going to do a poll or survey is we
want to understand public opinion but if
it's not statistically credible if we
can't believe what it's saying or if we
don't understand exactly what it's
saying then we might not have a good
sense of what public opinion actually is
so the first really important thing if
you're running any type of survey
whether it's in politics or government
or not is that you are taking a random
random sample
what does that mean well we go into a
lot more depth in it in our statistics
content on khan academy but it means
that you should look at the people the
voting population and it does get a
little bit nuanced and tricky on who are
likely voters but you would go to say
the voting population or the people in a
in an area whose opinion you care about
and you would want any one of them to
have an equal shot of being selected for
your survey
so good examples of random samples is
maybe you
take you have a random phone number
generator of likely voters in your
district and you call them up maybe and
even then you might say well hey maybe
certain types of people pick up the
phone and certain people don't or
certain people have a phone and certain
people don't so you have to be very
careful about this design but
examples of a non-random sample would be
to go hang outside of the democratic
party headquarters in your district and
just survey people coming out of that
building that would be very not random
and you would get very skewed results
now the next thing that you would want
when you are taking a survey is that you
want a large
population size
now typically speaking it's going to be
at least 500 folks but you're going to
see a lot of surveys that are about 500
to 1000 participants and sometimes in
statistics they'll say your n which is
the number of people you surveyed is 500
to a thousand and this is so you have a
good chance of getting close to the true
public opinion we're going to talk in a
second about margin of error the larger
this is and especially if you're doing a
true random sample this is so larger
larger it reduces
the you'll have a lower
margin
margin of error and i'll explain in
depth what a margin of error is in a
second
now another key thing is whatever you
ask in your survey it needs to be the
language needs to be as neutral and
unbiased as possible let's say there's a
new proposition you could get very
different results if the wording of the
question is do you support funds for
those in need or if you said do you
support funds for those who are not
working those could get very very
different results and this is there's
really an art to trying to get a neutral
unbiased question there last but not
least you want to make it very
transparent to the public how you
conducted your poll so that they can
decide for themselves how credible your
poll actually is
so with that out of the way let's look
at real poll results and then i'm going
to dig into what the idea of margin of
error is because you'll see this a lot
when you read the news
so this is from the sun sentinel in
florida they have a senatorial race
going on and it says despite millions of
dollars in television ad spending
florida's u.s senate race between bill
nelson and rick scott hasn't budged
a florida atlantic university poll shows
republican scott with 44 percent of
voters surveyed democrat nelson with 40
percent so the first thing you might say
is well what about this only adds up to
84
what about the other 16
well those could be undecided voters or
maybe there's a third candidate there
that's a four point advantage in scott's
favor but it's within the survey's
margin of error which means the race
could be tied or scott could have a lead
the fau business and economics polling
initiative survey of 800 florida
registered voters was conducted online
and through automated calls to people
with landline telephones
researchers said it had a margin of
error of plus or minus three percentage
points so let's think about whether this
is a credible poll and what inferences
we can make from it
so the first thing is were they
transparent about their methods and it
seems like there were this whole this
paragraph right over here they're very
transparent about their methods how many
people did they survey they say how they
actually conducted the survey and so
check on transparency and then because
they were transparent we can check
whether these other things are true
so first random sample they don't go
into a lot of depth on how it was
conducted online but if it is a neutral
site where any florida voter is equally
likely to show up
well then that might be a good random
sample now you have to be careful with
online because who has access to online
who does not have access to online who
might go to whatever site it is being
conducted on so this this has a couple
of question marks right over here and
then they say through automated calls to
people with landline telephones so once
again this seems reasonably random it's
along the lines that i talked about
earlier maybe they had some random phone
number picker in florida and they call
those folks but maybe you know there's
certain people who have landlines a lot
of people now only have mobile phones
there's certain people who pick up and
might answer things and certain people
who might not so as you can see there's
an art to getting a truly random sample
but you can tell that the florida
atlantic university group tried to get a
random sample
the next was the large population size
well they said a survey of 800 florida
voters so that's pretty good and it's
not just 800 for 800 sake it's the
number of voters that's going to drive
the margin of error
so this is a good time to say what is
the margin of error so a margin of error
is going to be associated with a
confidence level it's typically going to
be a 95 confidence level if they don't
tell you otherwise
and so what this means is is that 95
of the time when you take a random
sample of 800 florida residents
you will
get a result that is within three
percentage points of the true result
remember there's some true result we
don't know unless we could perfectly get
into everyone's head and this poll
is a way of trying to estimate that so
one way to think about within three
percent of what you got republican scott
is really you could create a confidence
interval where you could say the
confidence interval is going to be three
percent less than this which is 41
all the way to 3 more than this which is
47
and one way to think about it is there's
a 95 percent chance that this will
overlap with the true result
and you might say hey well the low end
of this range is still higher than
democrat nelson but that confidence
interval applies to democrat nelson as
well
so democrat nelson's confidence interval
would be between 37 percent 3 percent
less than this and 43 percent
3 percent more than this
there is still a reasonable chance maybe
the democrats at the higher end of this
range which could still mean that the
democrat could win even though the
headline numbers show a four point
advantage for the republican
and outside of the statistical error the
margin of error we're talking about you
have to remember that this poll is
before the actual election people change
their minds there's a whole campaign
going on so even if you were to get the
exact result this is just a snapshot in
time it could change on election day
now this last question where they asked
a neutral unbiased question
we don't know exactly at least just from
this article they might have published
it in the details of the poll but if
they ask something like who will you
vote for on the election on this day
that would be very neutral and unbiased
but if they say are you going to vote
for the public servant who has served
florida for many years or that democrat
guy
well that would be not unbiased